let's start at the beginning talk to us
about how this came across you came
across this story and how you managed to
speak to those people who were so so
suffering
great question kamalia and actually we
had seen um some reporting on it and
some social media reporting as well
YouTubers going to Philadelphia
and filming out of their Windows uh at
these people filming these people in in
these strange
drooping positions that they
involuntarily adopt once they have taken
the drug because it is a tranquilizer
and it puts them into a state of
semi-consciousness so we'd seen these
images
um but we were not prepared for for I
was not prepared for the scale of what
we saw and it was also clear that there
was some significant sensitivities
around this story obviously because of
the nature of it and because the people
involved or it's such a a difficult
period of their lives and so actually
getting access to being able to get
there and to earn the trust of both
those people who are using but also the
people who are trying to help them was
very difficult there's a a thing called
trauma porn which the the volunteers are
deeply concerned about people taking
advantage of the the images that they're
seeing but not actually spending time
with them and understanding the
challenges that both the the people
using and the volunteers are facing so
it was only when we got there that that
I was absolutely Blown Away by by the
scale of this we're talking block after
block after block of this area just
north of of the the shiny skyscrapers of
of Philadelphia uh where you can't
really find anyone who who is who is not
under the influence it's extraordinary
it's almost as if they have been pushed
into this part of of an American city
and the authorities have kind of gone we
can't we can't do anything about this
and as I say fentanyl is not a new
problem it was heroin 20 years ago then
it was fentanyl now it's compounded by
this this frightening new drug which is
not an opioid and so the the usual
overdose uh treatment that they that
they can use to deal with an opioid like
fentanyl does doesn't work for the
mixture that they're now taking which
compounds the problem even more yeah and
Mark as you mentioned going into a great
American city it feels very dystopian
seeing all those people block after
block as you describe um bent over like
that
um and the mixing of the drugs that
they're using that is because it's an
industry it's a drugs market and those
that are making this drug pushing it
onto these people have found that this
increases their margins I mean how much
does this thing cost for these these
users
three dollars or maybe five dollars for
each hit and sometimes that the dealers
will give out give them the uh a packet
out for free so that they can test uh
how it's going down and and increasingly
because
um the the short life of the half-life
sorry of um of the drug is is short it
means that they are taking maybe five
hits a day uh so when Once Upon a Time
they might have heroin once a day
they're now doing this five times a day
it's uh it's absolutely uh awful and I
got a real um a real sense of of the
challenges of addiction uh you don't
choose to become addicted you don't
choose to be in this position and there
were people as well that we met from
from all all walks of life uh Sam in my
report there one of the guys that that
we interviewed he described himself as
from a middle class family uh the eldest
of I think five children he said I'm the
only one who's ended up addicted how did
this happen to me you know a piece of my
soul is lost every day he said he
doesn't want to be there he's tried so
many times to come off this drug I was
really interested as well just briefly
Kamali at the the challenges that are
systemic for America
um that Ronnie the the woman who's
helping him in in the report there she
described to me that the situation she
often finds herself in is that that
someone who she's helping will ring her
up and say I'm ready I'm done I I'm
ready to go to to detox and there is as
Ronnie describes it like a five minute
window where she needs to get in her car
get to that person take them straight to
rehab because it will it will only be a
short window before the person decides
they can't cope anymore they need
another hit and so often she will take
that person to rehab and then the rehab
um uh facility will either say it's a
weekend we're not working or does that
person have health insurance the answer
probably no and so then the the window
has passed and that person will then go
back onto the Street and have another
hit it's absolutely awful